welcome to the live stream a lot to talk
about today glad you're joining me I'm
gonna wait just a moment or two for
people to connect there is really a lot
to talk about and I offhandedly
mentioned on the last stream that the
david pakman show may be sued for
something and a lot of people sort of
had questions about what that was and
that's understandable and I will say a
little bit more about that momentarily
without getting into details that I that
I should not get into yet but I will I
will discuss that because I've mentioned
it very off handedly not realizing that
it would be it would raise a lot of
questions and I got dozens of emails and
comments about it since the last stream
so I will be talking about that in a
second okay and then I also want to talk
about just I'm seeing a lot of really
concerning stuff on the left with a
couple of particular issues and I'm not
gonna go full Dave Rubin where I
denounce the left I'm actually gonna be
super specific and really it's sort of
quite the opposite but I'll talk about
that in a moment if this is your first
live stream I will tell you that it's
really live unless it's not unless
you're watching a replay the best way to
ask questions it's it's we often get a
lot of questions in the chat move so
quickly that the best way to get
questions to me and I will read and
answer them or if it's comments I'll
read and react to them is to use the
super chat super chat is the dollar
symbol towards the bottom of the chat
window and you can submit any question
you want sometimes the questions don't
make any sense sometimes they're
incoherent rants but that's okay that's
okay
and I will start digging into the super
chats shortly as they come in number
three any new members or new patrons
that pledge or sign up during the live
stream will get a live shout out and
thank you from me and I will sing your
praises in a beautiful way so david
pakman.com slash membership and
patreon.com slash david pakman show
there and please don't troll the chat
okay a lot of anti-semitism happens in
the
a lot of saying I'm a [ __ ] happens in
the chat all sorts of stuff like that
and there are a number of moderators
they have been deputized to do what they
need to do to keep the chat under
control so please no obvious trolling or
hate and so that you know today's
patreon target is 1880 1882 1880 patrons
during today's live stream that will
trigger a 59% membership discount code
we have had 55 56 57 and 58 percent
membership discount codes and if we get
to 1880 patrons today which is this is a
growing form of support for our program
it's really quite an amazing thing I
actually spoke to patreon today they
said you're doing really great we want
to just talk to you and see how it's
going because you are becoming one of
our top patreon channels so we want to
talk to you and I had a great
conversation with them today and they're
hugely supportive of what we're doing
and we are at 1863 we are trying to get
to 1880 if we do that I will trigger a
59 % membership discount code for you
and that will be a little bit later okay
so let me talk a little bit about what
some of my concerns I have with the left
now there are some people who like to
make these very very general statements
about how the left has left them right
and Dave Rubin is someone who has talked
about that and there's some some people
in my audience who are sensitive to that
idea and some who are not that's not
what I'm saying right I'm not gonna do
any kind of diatribe broadly against the
left but I'm concerned about a couple of
elements of the left that are and and
it's interesting because the theme
throughout what I'm about to identify is
a sort of authoritarian theme a leftist
authoritarianism and there's two areas
I'll talk about right now although I've
talked about others before one comes
with Trump Russia okay
so there is still a contingent on the
left that seems unwilling or unable to
accept that something very fishy is
going on with Trump Russia and this
started seven months ago and there were
there was a small contingent on the left
that said and probably nothing Hillary
really was that bad
period and I think it's stemmed from a
sort of fear or defensiveness among some
on the left that if there was collusion
between Donald Trump and Russia whether
Russia was responsible for getting Trump
elected or not that if you accept that
there was some attempt at least to help
Donald Trump from Russia that it sort of
excuses Hillary Clinton being a bad
candidate or it makes it seem as though
Hillary wasn't the bad candidate she
lost because of Russia and as a result
of making it seem like Hillary maybe
would have won otherwise that it hurts
Bernie Sanders now I was a Bernie
Sanders supporter in the primary that
that's no secret right it's been pretty
clear and I don't feel at all that
Bernie Sanders is weakened if we accept
that it looks more and more like Russia
has colluded with Donald Trump and
collusion is of course an umbrella term
that can encompass a number of different
actions and crimes I've talked about
that before I'm not gonna rehash that
right now I think it is a mistake for
the left to ignore Trump Russia as some
people on the Left are doing not all but
there are there is a contingent but
they're very loud online I don't know
how based on polling it doesn't seem
like they're it's actually that big of a
contingent but they're very very loud
online that says the entire Trump Russia
thing is meant to distract from the
corrupt failures of the DNC it's meant
to distract from Hillary's loss I think
my show is an example of why that's a
bogus narrative I have talked endlessly
about the problems of Hillary Clinton's
candidacy I have talked endlessly about
how Bernie Sanders was screwed by the
DNC and yet I recognize that Trump
Russia is not nothing
there have been no steps back on Trump
Russia as time goes we learn that it was
even bigger and more perverse than we
previously thought elements of the Trump
blackmail dossier are confirmed the
longer that we wait so at this point I
believe that if you are on the left and
you are insisting that Trump Russia is
nothing you have been ideologically
brain
in the same way that many trumpets have
been ideologically brainwashed now
here's the caveat the fact that I
believe Trump Russia is real and that it
doesn't devalue Bernie Sanders is
presidency it doesn't prop up Hillary
Clinton in any way that doesn't mean
that Democrats should only be talking
about Trump Russia in fact I think it's
the opposite I think Trump Russia is a
really good reason for Democrats to have
a plan for 2018 and 2020 that has
nothing to do with Trump Russia in the
sense that if Trump Russia is huge and
it leads to a resignation from Donald
Trump or impeachment hypothetical
doesn't even mean I think it's going to
happen or that you think it's going to
happen Trump goes away
you can't talk about Trump Russia in
2018 or 2020 anymore because Trump's
gone you need a platform you need a
platform that is truly progressive I've
talked about the issues that Democrats
should should take on there if Trump
Russia is nothing you also need a
platform that stands apart from that in
2018 and 2020 so this is why I know
nuance is boring right I either am fully
for this that the other thing or I'm
against this that the other thing the
truth is Trump Russia seems to be a
major concern right now for Robert
Moeller a grand jury has been impaneled
as we talked about last time but that
doesn't mean that Democrats need to be
running 2018 and 2020 on Trump Russia in
fact they need to be running truly as a
progressive platform I suggest taking a
really significant stand on a
single-payer health care I think that's
a great idea Bernie Sanders going to
introduce legislation we've got HR 676
in the house and you can disagree about
how much of a news shows coverage should
be about Trump Russia that's a perfectly
fair thing to discuss but at this point
to be arguing that it's nothing is like
the people that still email me and say
David self-driving cars are never
happening and we're never going to Mars
you're living in a fantasy world okay so
this is one area where I am very
concerned about a strain that exists on
the left there's another area that I'm
concerned with the left and it's not a
new area of concern last time I talked
about Venezuela this happened and it's
talking it's happening again now I have
been talking very clearly about
Venezuela
what my position is I believe that
Nicolas Maduro and Hugo Chavez are
authoritarian dictators masquerading as
leftist democratic socialists and this
is not something that my entire audience
agrees with me about and increasingly
the attacks from from within the left I
mean the right I'm not even dealing with
the right okay they are this sort of
appendage that won't go away
and disagrees with almost everything I
say but I'm really worried about what's
going on within the left there are some
less suppose and self-described
progressives Left leftists that email me
and they say Oh David you know your
attitude on Venezuela is tainted by your
neoliberalism I don't exactly have a
history of advocating for neoliberal
policies David you are Argentinian and
Argentinians don't like other South
Americans particularly brown South
Americans Argentinians are very very
white David you're you you came from an
upper-middle class argentinian family
which by the way couldn't be further
from the truth the reason my family
moved to the US is because we had no
money in Argentina and we had to get out
and try to find a way to make money
elsewhere so because I am wrongly
accused of being upper middle class in
Argentina I must not understand the
truth about Venezuela and then there are
sort of more specific arguments like
David the Venezuelan opposition is
us-funded astroturf meant to install a
puppet government which will allow the
u.s. to take control of Venezuelan oil I
would not even think for a moment of
denying that the United States
government and and foreign policy has
done horrible things in Latin America
South and Central America for the
purposes of self enrichment or strategic
political posturing I wouldn't deny that
for a second but there's a sort of
fundamental reality that is being missed
we can criticize American foreign policy
in Latin America over the last sixty
years and still recognize that there is
a non democratic regime in Venezuela and
I don't support non democratic
I don't support them anywhere I don't
support it in North Korea I don't
support it in the Islamic theocracies in
the Middle East and I don't support it
in Venezuela just because it has been
slapped with this amorphous label of
liberal democratic socialism when it is
actually authoritarianism which
masquerades as being left
authoritarianism or left populism but
it's very the lines become very blurred
from right-wing authoritarianism that's
the reality and there are many populist
narratives from Venezuelan leaders both
Maduro and the late Hugo Chavez that in
style and in substance are not that
different from some of what Trump ran on
his brand of right-wing authoritarian
populism so if you're looking for me to
change my tune and defend authoritarian
regimes that are not democratic with
fraudulent elections and voter purges
and whatever else the case may be it's
not going to happen if you want to have
a sensible discussion about how the
opposition should be supported in a way
that is not going to play in too
neoliberal American oil interests now
we're talking but nobody who's emailing
me wants to have that conversation it's
David you're some shill for American Leo
liberalism because you're an Argentinean
white Jew who hates South America blah
blah blah and it's bogus it's bogus and
it's it's completely indefensible when
it comes to the facts and if you're
gonna insist on on saying that to me
we're not really going to being able to
engage in any kind of sensible
conversation so is this a huge strain on
the left I don't know I don't know I
mean it's concerning because I am
getting a fair number of emails about it
and usually when I get an email about
something it does represent a lot more
people if someone you know a youtube
comment is very easy to leave David
you're a kook David you're a Jew if you
take the time to email me
you're probably representing an ideology
that at least exists in some significant
proportion among the audience and I'm
concerned about that as much as I'm
concerned about
as much as I'm concerned about the Trump
Russia stuff and sort of a blind hatred
for even exploring that on the left
because of I think the idea that it
somehow legitimizes Hillary Clinton I
don't believe it does I believe it's two
separate things so those are my thoughts
there and I'm glad to take questions
about that and about other things as
well real quick let me jump in and just
do a couple quick thank you so we don't
fall behind on these when we fall behind
it starts to get a little ugly
membership is the number one way our
program is funded you can get a
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership that allows you the
commercial-free all-access pass which
you can read about on the website as
well as the daily member-only bonus show
we have a 40% off coupon code that you
can use if you please and several people
have done that in the last few minutes I
want to send a big thank you to Marcus
Kane who has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership also a to
Marcus's also Marcus Muller Marcus
Muller signing up at david pakman.com
slash membership miguel rodriguez has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership and patrick eps has also
signed up thanks to all of you we do
depend on members particularly lately
since we're dealing with this when it
comes to YouTube revenue if you've not
been following the YouTube advertiser
boycott then you might not know that we
are dealing with an eighty five percent
cut to YouTube ad revenue but
memberships are helping to make up for
that and also I've set a target of 1880
patreon patrons this is only 17 and I'm
trying to make these targets realistic
if and when we get to 1880 patrons I
will create and give you a secret
it will only be made available to you on
the stream coupon code off for
memberships which will save you 59
percent off membership okay it doesn't
matter how much you pledged even a
dollar counts and we only need 17 $1
pledges to hit our target and I hope you
will join me in that and my desire would
be let's do this sooner than later I
found that when we don't hit the patreon
target until the end of the stream fewer
people end up taking it
I want as many people as possible to
take advantage of the discount let's
just get it done I think we can get it
we can get it done here with only like
5% of the people not even 5% of the
people on the stream and let's make it
happen and we'll get that coupon code
out there ok let me dive into some of
the super chats that are coming in here
a lot of interesting questions Isiah Roe
has sent the $10.00 super chat what do
you think of the report of Mike Pence
usurping Donald Trump in 2020 secular
talk thinks it's ridiculous and that any
primary challenger to Trump would be
destroyed to thoughts on that let's
think for a second about other so maybe
Mike Pence is planning to primary Donald
Trump maybe he's not I think it's
unlikely that Pence's thinking of
primary Donald Trump it's not a surprise
to Trump that Mike Pence created this
pact okay so what would be the reason
that this pact would be created other
than Pence is going to primary Trump one
Trump is not going to run for reelection
right if there's already the idea that
Trump won't run for reelection that
would be a reason for Mike Pence to
start laying the groundwork for running
in 2020 but also these PACs can be used
to support congressional candidates and
Senate candidates and that would be a
completely benign other than the
completely malignant nature of campaign
finance but if you accept the status quo
of campaign finance in the United States
this would be a sort of reason why Mike
Pence would create such as a PAC which
then would allow that money to be doled
out to other campaigns so I think it's
way too early to be thinking of Mike
Pence primary Donald Trump and there are
a number of other reasons why Mike Pence
might have created that that PAC and
we'll talk about that we'll talk about
that more on the program wolven heart
one has sent a $2 super chat in Canadian
currency to Canadian dollars no question
or comment thank you very much a rich
row pyth a [ __ ] has sent a $2 super chat
asking whether I listen to the
Backstreet Boys I don't listen to the
Backstreet Boys but I did see an
interesting documentary on Netflix about
the Backstreet Boys i watch a lot of
Netflix documentaries
and it was interesting I had no idea
that one of the Backstreet Boys is
basically it's not that he's lost his
voice but I believe he now suffers from
vocal dysphonia and he like can't sing
apparently I don't know if that's
improved the documentary is a couple
years old but no I don't listen to the
Backstreet Boys Matt oh eight oh six
seventy whoo if that is your birthday
Matt you had a birthday yesterday happy
birthday two dollars in super chat
wonder if these leftists are just
right-wing trolls that's interesting
right so are these suppose it leftists
saying there's no Trump Russia story
just right-wingers posing as left
winners are those claiming to be on the
left and defending nicolas maduro just
right-wing trolls I don't believe so i
genuinely don't believe so because some
of the people that email me about these
issues have been in contact with me off
and on for a long time and if so they've
been sort of pretending to be leftists
and reasonable on many issues for a very
long time I think that that would be
it's it's pretty pretty pretty contrived
over many years if that's the case
trickle-down economics has sent a $2
Super chat thank you very much and
Christina has sent a $2.00 super chat do
you ever nap do you ever take naps I
don't I I don't remember the last time
that I took a nap kind of think I might
have sort of inadvertently dozed off for
a few minutes last time I travel to
Europe as a result of jetlag which would
have been in April but no I don't take
naps I stopped taking naps very young I
remember even when I still lived in
Argentina I must have been four and I
was in preschool at after after lunch
there the kids would be divided into
three groups and it was outdoor recess
type fun indoor games like board games
and nap time and I did everything I
could not to draw a naptime card because
I hated it so much once there were it
was like limited by number right the
kids split up with the different
teachers it's amazing I even remember
this and once I ended up with an app
card it was a disaster I basically just
laid awake for the 45 minutes that were
allocated to that and it was not good it
was not good at all and I've not gone
back ever since Christina really don't I
really don't take naps and I hope that
that's not an offensive point of view to
anybody okay a couple stories we're
gonna be talking about tomorrow a while
ago I told you about this story here in
Massachusetts where a 17 year old woman
Michelle Carter was charged with
manslaughter for encouraging her
then-boyfriend to kill himself and he
did and it raised a lot of interesting
questions about whether about how number
one being a 17 year old whether this is
something she should be tried as as an
adult for or not but also questions
about you know you're not going to if
there's someone who is emotionally you
know I don't want to use stigmatized
words but someone who is not already
maybe dealing with depression you could
tell them to go kill themselves and it's
not going to have any impact right and
so when you say encouraging someone to
kill themselves could be manslaughter
that individuals mental state sort of
has to be considered by the person
making the offhanded suggestion that
they kill themselves in any way there
has now been a verdict in that case in
the Michelle Carter case she's been
sentenced to a minimum of 15 months
which is suspended for now pending
appeal and we're gonna talk about that
on the program tomorrow I'm also gonna
talk on the program tomorrow Donald
Trump seems to have been I don't want to
use the word cucked because it the right
is using it and sometimes I use it as a
goof but it seems that since chief of
staff John Kelly came in he has been
controlling Donald Trump's Twitter use
and it worked for a few days but then
this morning Trump exploded on Twitter
slamming senator dick Blumenthal from
Connecticut a Democrat for Blumenthal
talking about Trump's collusion saying
this guy lied about his Vietnam service
and it's so funny because it is true
that dick Blumenthal was deceptive about
NAM service even though he was stationed
in the United States during Vietnam he
has referred in front of veterans when
he was in Vietnam and of course he
wasn't and he's since apologized for
that distortion Donald Trump got five
deferments to Vietnam one because of his
bone spurs in his ankles he never he was
asked about this once and couldn't
remember which ankle it was and he
admitted it was actually a really minor
thing bla bla bla
it's projection projection projection
with Trump so we're going to talk about
that tomorrow as well as the fact that
he seems to be back on Twitter and it
really does seem as though at some point
someone was controlling his Twitter
usage so those are a few of the stories
we're gonna be looking at tomorrow we
also have a great interview tomorrow
with Stephen Schwartz Stephen Schwartz
has written and done a TED talk that's
super interesting about how citizenry
led change can happen and it can happen
violently or non violently and he's just
a super interesting guy and we're gonna
be interviewing him tomorrow and I think
it's gonna be very very interesting
let's jump back into the super chats
Travis the human has sent a $5 super
chat does the DNC need to distance
itself from regressive left vism how can
we do that I think that's a complex
question Travis because the DNC's main
problem is it's too
right-wing in other words it's sort of
like this corporate Democrats Inc
mentality where the real progressive
voices are generally speaking pushed to
the outside case-in-point Bernie in his
primary and I I think that the DNC you
know regressive left ISM if we're even
still using that term I've gotten away
from using the term I think that it's a
legitimate term in the sense of
describing it illiberal positions from
the suppose it left but it's now become
a catch-all for the right to just slam
the left with so I've gotten away from
using the term but I do express concerns
with the left being authoritarian
instead of progressive I don't think
that the DNC needs to distance itself
from regressive left ISM I think it's
important for the DNC not to use
the identity politics approach that is
not the good one I think that there's a
good identity politics and then there's
a destructive identity politics and
we've seen the destructive one crop up
in different parts within the the
progressive movement over the last
couple of years but no I don't I don't
think the DNC needs to do anything when
it comes to regressive left ISM I think
the DN C's got other lower hanging fruit
that they need to deal with Jacob ball
has sent the $20 super chat with just a
thumb up thank you very much very much
appreciate that Jacob and Frank macwrite
who is a super chat all-star as is Jacob
ball and Isaiah roe by the way Frank
macwrite sent the $20 super chats
Stephen Miller seems like a very scary
individual where do you see his place in
the future of this administration and do
you think we'll start seeing more of him
I hope we start seeing more of him in
the sense that he's incredibly
entertaining and it's just you know
hilarious and great fodder for programs
like mine I do think though that to the
extent that he's seen you know there's
these anti intellectualism has its own
set of concerns which we've talked about
many times pseudo intellectualism is
arguably more dangerous in the sense
that pseudo-intellectuals read people's
books like Mark Levin and Laura Ingraham
and think that they're really informed
on political ideology in history they
read Bill O'Reilly bestsellers about you
know Abraham Lincoln or JFK or whatever
and they think that they are
intellectuals they hear Talking Heads
like Stephen Miller and they believe
that they are genuinely informed and
listening to political thinkers and
they're not and in that sense it can be
really dangerous so that would be my
only concern with the resurgence of
Stephen Miller that we might see but
well you know I don't know what the
future is anybody could get fired at any
time John Kelly the chief of staff seems
to want to sort of clean up a lot of the
mess that is the Trump administration so
we will we will see what happens with
that I would like to see more of him
even though I recognize that the sort of
inherent Dean
let me do a couple more new member
thank-yous this program is mostly funded
by our audience we genuinely just can't
exist without help from the audience
okay so we are talking about membership
and patreon because we have suffered an
85 percent revenue hit as a result of
the YouTube advertiser boycott which
I've talked about ad nauseam and we'll
sort of spare you the details of right
now kitty Purim
kitty Purim has just signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership using the
40% discount code i vote at 17 and scott
miller has also signed up using that
exact same discount code so thanks now
we've got seven or seven or eight new
members during the live stream in just
the first half hour or so and I really
do appreciate that and I also want to
point to a patreon patreon is the no
mess no fuss way to say I like what you
do take a couple of bucks per month
period okay you go to
patreon.com/scishow you hit that red
button just pledge a dollar a month and
genuinely we've done demographic surveys
most of our audience can afford a dollar
a month if you can't I'm not talking to
you because I think the show needs to be
available and free to everybody
regardless of ability to pay that's sort
of the point of independent progressive
media which is let's spread ideas that
you're not going to hear in corporate
and particularly in right-wing media but
if you can throw in a dollar a month you
know we estimate only about one percent
of our audience contributes at all we're
approaching 400,000 subscribers on
YouTube if we could get even five
percent of our YouTube audience to throw
in a dollar I never have to mention the
advertiser boycott again and by the way
I would love never to have to mention
the YouTube advertiser boycott again
believe me as much as it's painful for
you it's painful for me because I'd
rather just be talking about politics
and not be in a funding crisis so that's
why we have launched the patreon and I
would like your help today
getting to 1,880 patrons that's only 17
one dollar contributions seventeen
dollars is all we need to source and I
will do you a solid
I will create a 59% membership discount
code I will only announce it here on the
live stream and you'll be able to sign
up for membership at a hugely hugely
discounted rate and that is something
that we've had some success with and we
are thinking also by the way it would be
great to get into patreon now because we
I had a phone call today with patreon
because they they like what we're doing
with it and they're you know interested
in supporting our fundraising on patreon
and we're trying to think of some new
rewards that we could put together for
patrons at different donation levels and
what I may do is Grandfather in some of
our existing patreon supporters once we
lock once we launched those extra so
that's another cool and exciting thing
so please do get those patreon
contributions in and I hope to be able
to create and release that fifty nine
percent discount code a little bit later
Christina sent a $2.00 super Chad do you
prefer iceberg romaine or spring mix so
it's a question about lettuce listen
iceberg right in the trash okay I am
completely opposed to iceberg lettuce it
is basically water I find it completely
bland in every way and by the way one of
my least like salads I went to a wedding
rehearsal dinner not that long ago and
they come out with this wedge salad
which is basically it's like 1/4 or 1/8
or 1/3 of an entire head of iceberg
lettuce with a bunch of blue cheese
ranch dressing and bacon bits I don't
even eat bacon so it wasn't you know I I
had it without bacon I mean this this it
was in a totally abortive salad okay so
iceberg lettuce I'm against romaine I
like a little more and spring mix is
sort of my go-to you can use arugula
also and arugula is not bad I believe
they all sort of I think they all cost
the same you can get those organic
packages for 399 and I'll mix it up but
never ever ever iceberg lettuce please
by all means let's not let let's wrap up
iceberg lettuce Vox turbulent a 5 euro
one of you candidate could propose to
make the popular vote effective and not
the Electoral College its embrace okay
yeah so I don't know what you're talking
about specifically there is something
called the National popular vote
interstate complex or something like
that and the idea is if enough states
sign on to give all electoral votes to
the winner of the popular vote then you
could effectively have enough popular
votes available based on the national
popular vote winner and we talked about
that closer to the November election and
so I don't a hundred percent understand
the question but there are ways that
states could get together and start
making the popular vote effectively the
way we elect the president without
needing a change to the Constitution etc
I hope I'm sort of explaining or at
least answering your question Bill
Pierce has sent a $35 super chat that is
the new high watermark for the live
stream no question or comment thanks
very much bill I appreciate it
gr has sent the $2 super chat sup DZ
good job love gr PS love you all all
right gr checking in thank you very much
I appreciate that Hobbiton has sent the
20 British pound super chat people say
that injustice against whites or males
does not exist I disagree I don't think
it outweighs oppression of non-whites
and females at all but I think people
assume that only if one sides problems
exist the other can't
so listen Hobbiton I conceptually do not
disagree that you can find injustice
against males or white people no doubt
about it particularly in countries where
white people are not the majority in the
context of the United States I think
it's undeniable that at large there is
quite a bit of low-hanging fruit in
terms of discrimination and mistreatment
that exists against non-whites and non
males but you know I think I had a good
conversation with Peter Bogosian about
this the other day even he admits that
yeah white privilege is real white
privilege is real and yet there are
still a lot of other complexities in
terms of privilege that that are
relevant to talk about in our society
reduce has sent a five-dollar super chat
I'm more worried about the Trump
propaganda news network than I am one
talking thumb named Miller what do you
think yeah I I am trying to figure out
Trump propaganda news network what's the
name of the I'm trying to figure out we
got a bunch of those documents Trump
launches his own propaganda network what
is the name of that I'm just looking it
up I can't believe I forgot a Lima
Kennedy is gonna be part of it real news
Fox News doesn't provide first episode
was launched by Trump daughter-in-law
lera Trump okay I'm not finding the name
of this network but yeah I think that
that is concerning and it's also really
concerning that you know we I'm getting
calls from people reasonable people who
say how do we figure out what's fake
news and what's real news should the
government may be established a list of
approved or real news stations bad and I
understand the sort of knee-jerk
reaction and saying there somebody
should create a list of what's real news
and what isn't but it's very dangerous
when it's the government in power that
is doing that and I agree REE disk I'm
concerned about the Trump propaganda
news network I'm also concerned about
Stephen Miller right I'm concerned about
both Tony Merritt has sent a $5 super
Chad did you see that bit on Fox News a
few days ago where they brought on a
twelve-year-old girl to sing Trump's
praises I found it particularly
disturbing no fox news twelve-year-old
trump let's see what that's about
Oh
Trump's twelve-year-old supporter wow
yeah I'm in a book market and watch it
usually I can't take this stuff it's
like really vile it it almost borders on
child abuse in some ways but yet I
haven't seen that Tony but I'll check it
out
Jacob ball has sent a $2 super check
David are you kosher no I think because
I said I don't eat bacon maybe some
people thought I might be kosher I'm not
I stopped eating pork several years ago
for a couple reasons number one
I read about because of the digestion of
the pig it seems it's less healthy to
eat pork than some other meats at first
I thought it was just sort of an old
wives tale but I did at least what I
felt was a substantial amount of
research at the time and it seems that
there is something to that and number
two I found out pigs are as smart as
dogs and I wouldn't eat a dog and I've
been around pigs and they really do
react the way that dogs do in terms of
reacting to humans and following people
around and all that type of thing and I
just started I sort of went away from it
and really I don't eat I don't eat I
basically stopped eating red meat I will
if I go to a nice steak house at a
conference if they're taking us to a
dinner or something I'll have red meat
but I'm sort of mostly off of red meat
and trying to do more than Mediterranean
diet more fish and seafood although not
too much because you got the mercury and
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
you got to be careful about everything
but anyway long story short I'm not
kosher I eat shrimp shellfish I mix I
mix meat and dairy and all of that stuff
but I do not eat pork okay will Castillo
has sent the $10 super check I love your
work and your message drive on
well thanks will I do appreciate that
and we're gonna do our best to keep it
going
and part of that is and I want to get to
a couple more thank you as part of that
is continuing to grow our support from
our audience okay and I want to thank
new members signing up in the last few
minutes Laura Duggan thank you so much
for signing up Steve been Alima
Steve been Alima has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership and
alexander hay has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership thank you
very much we have a coupon code
available to you that coupon code is I
voted 17 you're under no obligation to
use the discount but it's available to
you and I have no problem whatsoever
with you using that discount also we are
trying to get to 1880 patrons by the end
of this stream we started the evening at
1863 and I want to thank Jason Hogue
Matt Missoula for their pledges Jason
Hogue has just pledged two dollars a
month at patreon.com slash david pakman
show matt matt sola has pledged five
dollars a month at patreon.com slash
david pakman show so we started the
evening at 1863 we are now at 1865 and
only 15 patrons away now why what is
1880 mean why 1880 if you can help me in
getting to 1880 patrons by the end of
the night I will create and release to
you a 59 percent coupon code off of
membership and you will then be able to
subscribe at a 59 percent discount for
membership you'll get all the great
member benefits and you can keep that
rate for as long as you want so
tonight's goal it is 1880 and I would
really appreciate your support getting
to that the broader goal is 2,000 and
we're really getting closer you know
what when we had 800 patrons I thought
it's gonna be a long time before we get
to 2,000 because I promised when we get
to 2,000 patrons I would do an entire
broadcast show from the David Pakman
show studio to all of our 200 radio and
TV affiliates with my hair like this and
this is what happens when I don't
control my hair with product and it's a
very disturbing image for a lot of
people but I've committed to doing this
when we get to 2,000 patrons and at the
rate we're going we're gonna be there
we're gonna be there at some point
relatively soon so if that's interesting
to you it's yet another reason to make a
pledge tonight but really 1880 is the
target and I hope we get there and
that'll be helping a lot of people
afford a membership when they otherwise
could not because we will discount
memberships 59% if we get to 1880 okay
getty germany has sent a five euro super
chat and but I've not forgotten in about
five 10 minutes I'm gonna talk about the
threat of a lawsuit that the david
pakman show has received and it's not
funny and it's kind of uh it's kind of
stressing me out I'm not gonna lie but
I'll talk about that in five or ten
minutes
getti Germany has sent a five euro super
check my friend quarter mix should stop
playing Ark survival evolved please tell
him thanks and coffe Fe I have no idea
what Ark survival evolved is I don't
know who quarter mix is but if Getti
Germany has the sense to purchase super
chat for David Pakman show live streams
then it's probably someone that is
trustworthy the d2j bug has sent a five
Canadian dollar super chat no question
or comment I appreciate that
Maria Romero has sent a five dollar
super chat just helping support the show
Thank You Maria very much appreciate
Maria is a total david pakman show
all-star maria is I believe correct me
if I'm wrong Maria or not either way
it's I think it's gonna help tout your
credentials a member a patron and a
pretty consistent super chatter so I
really appreciate that Maria gr has sent
a $2.00 super chat copying a question
from Bill Pierce into the chat $35 oh I
guess bill Pierce meant to send a
question and it didn't work okay the
question was David what are your
thoughts about movements such as
Portland resistance that can trump
confront Trump supporters when they hold
rallies these confrontations always
become violent what are your thoughts
okay so I am against criminality and I'm
against violence that being said I am in
favor of showing up for a counter
protest I think that that's a really
good thing and we actually had a really
really good conversation about this
today with Jessica Peak low the context
was protests outside of abortion clinics
and family planning clinics where
anti-abortion activists will make it
really uncomfortable for women seeking
family planning services you have to
kind of weave your way through
protesters and on the one hand you have
to respect the free speech rights of the
protesters at the same time there are
court decisions that as part of the
First Amendment support the individual's
right to be free from hearing certain
types of speech if they want to and thus
if you
this aggressive mob shouting about
abortion or about whatever at people who
are just trying to go about their day
that that may go beyond the limits of
free speech and so legally this is way
above my paygrade is someone who's not a
lawyer and really only leads it reads
about this stuff as a layperson but I
think that there there's an interesting
question there I completely support
counter protests in the sense of these
are constitutionally protected forms of
speech and at the same time I'm against
violence and I believe that it's it's
best not to commit crimes so let me talk
about okay let me do a couple more
thank-yous
because I don't want to fall behind and
I'm going to talk about the pending
possible lawsuit patreon.com slash david
pakman show Tyler Drew's has just
pledged two dollars a month Tyler thank
you you're a great person
tired crayon I'm not sure if that's the
legal name probably not tired crayon has
pledged two dollars a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show this
gets us to 1867 patrons if you get just
13 more patrons we will hit our target
of eighteen eighty why do you care about
getting to 1880 patrons because you will
be doing a huge service to all of our
audience because if we get to eighteen
eighty by the end of the live stream
I'll create and announce to you a 59
percent membership discount code which
would be the biggest membership discount
code we've ever done a few weeks ago we
hit a target I did 55 percent we hit
another target last week I did 56 and 57
percent earlier late last week I did 58
percent and I am going on record right
now with peace and love that if we get
to 1880 patrons I will create and
release a 59 percent discount code okay
I'm gonna talk to you about a possible
lawsuit against the David Pakman show
I am NOT going to name any of the
individuals the law firm or anybody else
involved here because I'm still hoping
we don't get sued but it's actually not
looking good and I want to preface this
by saying
by saying if you are an attorney and you
might be able to help us pro bono if we
get sued it would be really great to
hear from you now rather than later
because well because it would just be
good to know if we're gonna have that
support because this I don't know how
expensive this could get but it could
get bad
you've heard of patent trolling patent
trolling a lot of podcasters of dead
dealt with patent trolling we are not
dealing with patent trolling we are
dealing with its cousin which is
copyright trolling I don't want to go
any further than to say this relates to
an image or video that was used on our
program I believe within the boundaries
of fair use although that is something
that you have to assert and prove in
court so if we're ever really trying to
demonstrate fair use it's because we've
been sued and it has gone to court and I
hope that doesn't happen
we received what is called a demand
letter some people call these extortion
letters demanding a lot of money for
this picture or video which could have
been licensed according to the firm that
has contacted us for a fraction of what
they're now demanding and they are
claiming damages and all this stuff now
they are threatening with a lawsuit
they're asking for more money than we
have to give them and so I'm not able to
do that and I'm making very clear that
money is not going to materialize
magically if they sue us and that it
would be really great not to do that and
that this is just a really bad thing and
I'm also making clear that it I don't
even have a lawyer currently
representing me because starting to pay
a lawyer
hour after hour to represent me in this
would also be very expensive so the long
and short of it is we're being
threatened with a lawsuit the law firm
is insisting that if we don't pay up we
will be sued obviously if that happens
this would be a suit I am told in
federal court which can get very
expensive so listen
this may be a sign that we have gotten
to the point of influence such that we
are on the radar of people right and and
for a little tiny show that started in a
basement community radio station that
now actually has some distribution and
some staff and support from our audience
that's a really great thing but at the
same time this is causing real concern
and if we get sued it could be a major
major issue so anyway if you needed any
more impetus to make a contribution to
make us more financially solvent in
general particularly given what's been
going on with the YouTube ad boycott ad
revenue dropping eighty five percent for
us over the last several months not a
bad time to throw in a dollar at
patreon.com slash david pakman show but
that's it and I don't really want to say
anymore because you know the law firm
always tells you it's all secret and
confidential it's really not but I want
to wait before really going to you and
saying this is what's going on are there
any lawyers who can help etc because I'm
hoping it can get resolved in some kind
of better way but yeah and you know some
people suggest that we could get a pro
bono attorney but every everybody I've
looked at really just works with
nonprofits we're not a non-profit we're
just not a huge company right and
particularly because of the YouTube ad
boycott there's even less free money
floating around so to speak so if there
was any lawyers use our website contact
form ideally someone who works in
Internet intellectual property and yeah
so that's the long and short of it I saw
some people joking I hope Dave Reubens
not suing you he's not that's not that's
not where this has come from this is
coming from the the d2j bug has sent a
to Canadian dollar super chat it's not
easy being green alright very good
Maria Romero $5 super chat that's
correct thank you David happy to do it
the show is totally worth it that's
right Maria is absolutely right as a
member patron and super chatter it is
worth supporting media that you believe
in purple chime sent a $2 super chat
what deep deep dives are you planning
or considering let me give you the list
because we've got them scheduled already
we have four deep dives currently
scheduled to be released during our
upcoming summer vacation okay number one
where are they hold on yes classical
liberalism is pretty effing conservative
that's the title of our deep dive into
classical liberalism and that trend by
the way these these deep dives
they take weeks if not months to do and
this is part of why we're trying to
raise money because I don't want to stop
doing this stuff and it takes staff
hours above and beyond the daily
production of the show we've got this is
ready for you guys
classical liberalism is pretty effing
conservative voter fraud and voter
suppression voter fraud which the right
alleges is a problem is not voter
suppression which the left alleges is a
problem actually is as demonstrate
demonstrated by facts really good deep
dive ready for you guys their socialism
has never worked debunked okay that's
another topic this idea that socialism
has never worked and will never work
blah blah blah blah blah it's not true I
am NOT a socialist but I recognize that
it's fallacious to say socialism has
never worked we're going to be doing a
deep dive there a lot of you people have
asked for deep dives into economic
systems and this is gonna be a really
really good one and lastly the violent
left the violent left is something it's
a trend we're hearing about on the right
oh the left is so violent now it's not
true and we are going to pick that apart
in great detail so those four are in
production or ready for you we're also
going to be doing a deep dive on race
and IQ this sort of relates to the
recent Sam Harris controversy with the
bell curve dude I forget his name
Charles Marie Marie is his last name but
it's only partially going to deal with
that we've also got a great miniseries
planned about critical thinking which I
think will be a really really good piece
and it's arguably one of the most
ambitious things that we are we are
tackling
and we will be dealing with that
probably after the vacation okay Killa
Luigi has sent a $2 super chat guy
Moresby idea is the best idea think B
okay I don't know what that is guy
Moore's B idea I will look that up
Rhonda Moses Rhonda Moses has sent a $2
super chat no question or comment thank
you very much James Stockdale has sent a
to British pound super chat what about
contacting Ben Shapiro about the threat
of lawsuit he's a lawyer yeah that's an
interesting idea but I think he's pretty
busy between speaking and his radio show
and his YouTube channel and I think he's
got a bunch of kids I don't know how
many so that's an interesting idea but
I'm hoping that we'll be able to find
someone in our audience that might be
able to help us with this threat of
threat of a boycott okay we've got new
memberships and patreon we've got only
about fifteen or twenty minutes I think
I can hang in terms of the live stream
we only need another 13 patrons to get
to 1880 I really want to do this okay
every time we do one of these big
discounts I know that for for many of
you based on your income you might say
well if you can afford a $3 membership
you can afford a $6 membership that's
not necessarily true there are many
people who email me and they say David
listen I'd love to sign up at six or
twelve dollars a month the truth is I
can't but I do value your work and I
want to support the work that you do
when you do these livestream discounts I
then I'm able to sign up for the entire
year for like 25 bucks and that's really
worth it and thanks to all those patreon
donors so I this actually does matter
and it does help build our membership
base if we get 13 more patrons tonight
and that gets us to 1880 I will create
this coupon code and generally dozens of
people take advantage of the coupon code
okay so if you value the show even to
the tune of $1 a month just throw in a
dollar and that will be a really really
great thing for us and it'll also
further it'll have a neck
multiplier effect for a rat lack of a
better term because it will allow other
people to sign up for membership so
we're only thirteen away help me make it
happen and then as far as memberships go
we do have a few more new members that I
want to say hello to who have signed up
at david pakman.com slash membership
Amanda Thompson Paul Moore Andrew sites
Barbara Bazar and Pedro Roberts okay
thank you so much to the six of you who
have signed up for membership and said
hey you know what I like what you're
doing enough to support it financially
it's a beautiful thing let's get to that
eighteen eighty and I'll release that
coupon code okay more questions still
coming in purple chime has sent a ten
dollar super chat those deep dives sound
great here's a super chat to support
them thank you very much purple chime
and also another great a great option is
just throw in a couple bucks a month
through patreon and support the ongoing
production of these long-form
investigative type deep dive videos
Audrey Lee has sent a five British pound
super chat I've been listening to
channels like secular talk for ages and
it's stressing me out how Russia is
being underplayed tips for convincing
liberal friends you know generally
Audrey the problem is when someone's
been ideologically committed to believe
or not to believe something it's very
hard to throw facts at them to convince
them a better idea would be asking
questions like for example for a lot of
these people on the Left who reject the
Trump Russia collusion story
irrationally so part of it is they
believe that admitting that Trump Russia
collusion may have been a factor in the
election and again that's that's like
the smallest part now it seems that all
this criminality that might have taken
place is separate from whether the
election hinged on that collusion a lot
of these people believe that it sort of
deal Ajith amaizing Bernie Sanders is
candidacy or D legitimizes the DNC's a
favorite ism of Hillary Clinton if Trump
and Russia colluded say to them what do
you believe it would say about Bernie
Sanders
if Trump and Russia did collude and
presumably they would say you know it
wouldn't actually say anything because I
believe Bernie could have defeated Trump
no matter what and then you can say you
know what I agree with you and that's a
separate issue from whether or not Trump
and Russia colluded I think having that
type of question and an answer session
would be more useful than sort of
stating facts I don't know that that is
going to convince to too many people
David Mitnick has sent a five dollar
super cheque do you think that
capitalism is compatible with ecological
sustainability should we think about
alternative systems to stave off off
catastrophe well listen I think that
well regulated capitalism sort of a demo
so Shiell democracy the way that a lot
of the scandinavian countries have gone
if done thoughtfully and if done with
full buy-in from the population which we
don't have here in the united states i
think that it could be compatible with
ecological sustainability the brand of
capitalism that we're hearing a lot
about from the right the unbridled
unrestrained unregulated capitalism it's
not going to be compatible with
ecological sustainability because there
is a financial incentive to get as much
money as you can from the planet's
resources and from the people on the
planet without concern for the future
and you will have libertarians who say
it'll work itself out because eventually
if companies pillage the resources and
pollute too much they'll kill off
customers and then they won't have any
customers to buy their products that is
is far enough away that it's not
actually going to dissuade companies
today from doing what they can to make
as much money as possible Brian Finley
has sent a five British pound super chat
as someone from Argentina what do you
think of the sovereignty of the Falkland
Islands you know this is embarrassing
but I've mostly grown up in the US and
while I know quite a bit about
Argentinian history the Falkland Islands
controversy is not one that I am as
familiar with as I would like to be what
I do want to tell you is that I am NOT
an irrational defender of the Falkland
Islands being Argentinian I know that
there are people in the audience who
will hear me say I don't know enough
about it to comment really intelligently
or articulately
I am NOT using that as code
or I believe the Falkland Islands are
truly Argentinean I actually I genuinely
don't know enough about it and I know I
should but my knowledge of Argentinian
history is outside of the Falkland
Islands conflict okay we do have other
patrons to thank I want to send a big
THANK YOU to ishani Sen who has made a
$2 pledge at patreon.com slash david
pakman show we started the evening at
1863 patrons we have now thanks to the
help of five people climbed to 1868
patrons I am starting to be slightly
skeptical that we will hit eighteen 1880
I think it would be tremendous for us to
hit 1880 and I have made a pledge to you
which is that if we hit 1880 patrons
tonight anybody who wants a membership
discounted at fifty nine percent will be
able to get a membership discounted at
fifty nine percent that's the promise
I've made we are targeting 1880 patrons
however I don't know that we're gonna
get there because I can't stick around
that much longer as I do have to start
working on tomorrow's program in more
detail if it's at all worth it to you to
generate this fifty nine percent
discount
we are only twelve contributions away on
patreon twelve small one dollar
contributions helped me there and then I
will help everybody who's been waiting
around for a discounted membership with
a fifty nine percent discount code in
the meantime let me tell I already told
you about the deep dives that are
upcoming on the program let me tell you
a little bit about the guests that are
coming up as I mentioned earlier
tomorrow we'll be speaking to Stephen
Schwartz he is a scientist a futurist
and author we're going to be talking
about social movements that have
successfully created impactful change on
our planet on Wednesday and Thursday we
will be having a two-part interview with
Charles durbur who has written a really
good book about how to fight the Trump
agenda and to sort of really try to
prevent
more of this type of nonsense from
happening in the future it's a really
specific hands-on guide and I think
you're really gonna enjoy the
conversation with Charles durbur and
that is going to get us to our vacation
okay and during vacation we'll be
releasing on YouTube for you for
long-form deep dives which have been in
production for a while we will be doing
one deep dive on classical liberalism
will be doing one deep dive on voter
fraud and voter suppression will have a
25 or so minute piece on the so-called
the violent Left which doesn't really
exist and we will also have a long-form
video on how socialism has debunking the
talking point that socialism has never
worked and then when we return from
vacation I'll be interviewing attorney
Mike Papantonio and big friend and
supporter of the David Pakman show
his second legal thriller novel is
coming out in September and I just
received a preview copy of it and his
first book was great there's a character
named David Pakman in paps first book
I'm told that I am NOT in the second
book but that the story is just as good
so I'm gonna be reading it on the plane
on vacation and we'll also be
interviewing ASSA our back and our back
has written a graphic novel explaining
the concepts of entropy and the second
law of thermodynamics and there's been a
lot of demand from the audience for more
science stories and I think that entropy
and the second law of thermodynamics are
two topics that are really difficult to
explain in a way that makes sense to
laymen including me and so we're going
to be speaking to us our back when we
return from vacation and I'm really
really looking forward to that we are
getting closer when it comes to patreon
we have received two more pledges we
have a $2 a month pledge from Roger
Rivera and a dollar a month pledge from
Nicholas yeah cool oh thank you thank
you to both of you we are now at 1870
patrons okay tend to go let's not folks
come this far in approaching 1880 which
will trigger a 59% discount code and
fall short we only need 10
more single dollar contributions we just
got one more of them from Mariah Codes
who has made a $2.00 a month pledge
meaning we have nine to go nine to go
with ten minutes to go
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
let's do it let's do it I think it would
be a really great thing for us to
achieve that gr Issa has sent a $2.00
super chat saying merely xoxo meaning
hug and kiss hug and kiss I think that's
what xoxo means anyway Arisa thank you
so much for the super chat let me now do
something I've been trying to do for a
while or rather I've been meaning to do
for a while but I haven't always had
time to let me take a look through the
non super chat discussion to see if
there's any specific questions I can
answer quickly because I do want to be
available for questions and comments to
everybody not just people who send super
chats would I'd rather vote for the rock
Kid Rock or a literal Rock I would say
probably the rock I think he is he's a--
is he a liberal or is he like a
libertarian and i don't know definitely
not Kid Rock that I can tell you for
sure okay let's see what else we've got
here Bill Pierce talked about his
question became separated we dealt with
that already
pigs are treated poorly in factory
farming yeah related to me not eating
pigs
people cheering about new members
supporting the show wonderful work
we had the how fro can you go you know I
have thought about growing my hair out
longer for a while so the context is I
put this picture up before and I said
that if and when we get to two thousand
patreon patrons that I will do an entire
broadcast show with my hair like this if
I have thought about growing my hair
even longer the only concern is I feel
like there would be an in-between phase
before it gets actually long where it
would look nuts and I don't know exactly
how I'd manage that out in public so
I've thought about growing my hair out
but
that uh it's gonna happen but I think it
would be would be a pretty and
interesting thing okay who would sue you
I'm truly upset well maybe someday I
will tell you but it is not good and I
really hope we can avoid litigation
because that would not be good let's see
what other questions we've got in the
regular chat a lot of people talking
about free speech but but put the BA it
better not be dave rubin suing you i
mentioned that it's not who here is a
lawyer that's a good question fair use
is a gray area that is a very very good
point no doubt about it people asking
what video is the one that we would be
sued over i don't want to say i don't
want to say because if I said what video
or image the lawsuit would be over you
could figure out who holds the copyright
you could Google who that person is
working with and then the last thing I
need is our audience starting to contact
the law firm right now but I will
eventually tell you what it is that's
going on
sounds like legal extortion could the
ACLU help yeah there's a lot of a lot of
questions about that I'm glad people are
reacting to that I'm glad because it is
a really really big deal where's the
link to donate though I don't know what
link you mean Nikita but if you go to
patreon.com/scishow there's a big orange
or red depending on the color
temperature of your monitor button this
has become a patron and that is the way
you do to do it what else do we have any
other questions that I want to grab from
here people saying they like Kyle
kolinsky they don't like Kyle kolinsky
he's pretentious he's good I stopped
listening I'm continuing to listen
alright well that's good it's great that
everybody is free to watch or not watch
anything that they want some people like
jimmy dore some people don't like jimmy
dore jimmy doors controversial among our
audience not not everybody likes him
some people really really like him okay
so thanks to everybody there a couple
more super chats but first we've got a
another patreon donation we're get this
is going to be it's gonna be a close
race to the finish
Richard a Gil V has made a pledge of $1
a month
and with that pledge from Richard we now
have 1872 patrons eight patrons to go
eight patrons to go and minutes to go in
the livestream let's just do it let's
get those last eight dollar
contributions and get that 59% discount
code new members also that I want to
thank we have a new membership from
Elena Cardenas or Cardenas who has
pledged I'm sorry who has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership so
that is a a big big thing and available
to everybody
membership patreon this is how we are
supported and also by the way the
patreon total the reason we're at 1872
is also because of a $2 pledge from
Claire Phillips so Claire thank you very
much I appreciate that as well
[Music]
1872
patrons remaining and that is a
beautiful thing eight to go let's do it
let's not it's very you know I I know
that some people say David even if you
don't hit the number of patrons you can
still create the discount code but I
feel like that's disingenuous in the
sense that if it's really a patreon
challenge if then I say well it doesn't
matter I'll just create the code it kind
of defeats the purpose of it you know so
I feel like it's it's the right thing to
do to stick to the parameters that I
have established here a few more
questions let's give a little more time
to see if we can get any more of those
patreon pledges in and get to 1880 Wow a
bunch of new patreon super super chats
came in Christina
sent a $5 super chat thanks for taking
my silly questions I love the live
stream love the show and appreciate how
hard you work in the time you put in
thank you so much Christina that does
mean a lot to me
game fire 74 two dollars biggest pet
peeves I can't even start to deal with
that right now game fire but we have an
entire audience question video and in
fact let's see if I can quickly find it
on pet peeves that we need an hour or
two super chat probably just for that
let me see if I can find the video
once did on pet peeves I'm not easily
finding it but it's in the audience
questions playlist on YouTube
Jacob ball has sent a $2 super chat
Pakman misspelled is better than kyle is
better than door is better than ruben
very interesting very very interesting
Jacob that is your hierarchy there gr
has sent a $2 super chat F the
litigation against the D Z and F Trump
alright gr well there you go Emmett
Cashman has sent a $2 super chat what
are your thoughts on Kamala Harris
Kamala Harris I believe I never know the
pronunciation people asking about the
back I'll get to that later I don't have
a problem with camel Harris I think she
did a great job asking Jeff Sessions
questions during that hearing my problem
with camel Harris is that you have these
so-called elites Democratic donors that
are starting to donate to her presumably
for the 2020 presidential election and I
think it is way too damn early to start
thinking about that anytime that the
Democratic establishment of donors
rallies behind someone three years early
we end up with the types of problems we
were in in the 2016 election I don't
like it one bit and that is my only
concern around
Kamla Harris it's not about particular
political positions at this point I
generally like her I've liked her for a
while but I am I am worried about that
when you start hearing about the
Democratic establishment already
rallying behind someone three years out
when we've got the 2018 midterms which
could give control of the House and
Senate back to Democrats that's where
you've got to be focusing I mean that
that's that is where the the money and
energy needs to be spent we're closing
in we're trying to get to 1860 patrons
Zach Clark has made a $2.00 per month
pledge I think there might have been one
other pledge that came in that hasn't
pinned me yet we are at 1874 patrons we
are only six patrons away from the
target of 1800
80 let's not fail this one let's not
fall just six patrons shy of the target
I am actually I I have such a degree of
confidence which may end up being wrong
but I hope that it's it's good
confidence that we are going to reach
1880 patrons before the end of the
stream that I am going to pull up the
interface I use for creating coupon
codes because I think we are closing in
on the 59% membership discount code so
I'm going to set that up we've got a $2
pledge from Johanna Linden which again
inches inches us just a bit closer to
1880 I'm going in right now to the
coupon section because I do want to be
ready I do want to be ready in case we
reach that and if not then we'll deal
with it next time
we can always deal with it next time but
we are now only 5 patrons away from 1880
and it would be a real shame if we
didn't get to that
Jacob Ball has sent a $2.00 super chat
merely to correct the spelling of my
last name as Packman PA que ma n thank
you very much agent 355 has sent a $2.00
super chat contact lawful masses with
Leonard French is that some kind of a
public interest law firm lawful masses
with Leonard French I'm googling that ok
I don't know a copyright attorney that's
interesting do they do pro bono work
that's a very very interesting question
YouTube channel host and copyright
attorney that's interesting ok I will
look into that KH has sent a twenty
dollar super chat really enjoy your show
thank you very much I really appreciate
that very very much appreciated let me
quickly mention people asking about the
stuff behind me this right here this is
one of my hold on here we go this is one
of my paintings it's been there for a
while because it's the latest painting
and I haven't done a new one for a while
this bag over here I was away for the
weekend and it's just miscellaneous
items that I've not put away yet which I
should put away
this is a snare drum with not one not
two but three too large and one small
practice pad on top of it with my
drumsticks and metronome down here we've
got all my drum books I do play drums I
live in an apartment though so I can't
really be loud and as a result I've got
a snare drum with three practice three
practice pads on it to deaden it Quin
Maliki has sent a $2 super chat contact
the National Lawyers Guild for help with
the lawsuit that is interesting that is
interesting that's an interesting idea
I will bookmark that as well thank you
very much purple chime have sent a $5
super chat please tackle this argument
anti-semitic comments and chats are
trolls expressing free speech and
shouldn't be taken seriously or censored
listen free speech doesn't apply in chat
for private YouTube channels right I
mean we this is not a free speech issue
because we are not the government we can
manage our YouTube channel however we
want criticisms of Israel are not
conflated with anti-semitic comments on
our channel we do not ban for criticisms
of Israel I believe that these are two
different things
blatant anti-semitism will will will
trigger bans and blocks and that is
completely a legitimate thing and I have
no problem with it is not a free speech
issue okay let's see what we've got
going on with patreon we are trying to
get to 1880 pledges Abraham Tchibo has
pledged $2 a month
Steven seda has pledged $1 a month which
now puts us squarely three patrons away
from 1880 I've got five minutes left
before I've got a run let's not miss
this we are only three patrons away
three single dollar contributions from
me creating a custom 59% discount code
for membership and we just need three
more $1 pledges let's make it happen as
I deal with some final super
it's Audrey Lee has sent a $2 a to
British pound super chat can maybe help
legally check your website messages
absolutely will absolutely will when I
finish up here and of course well yeah I
mean I don't you're sending British
pound super chats I presume I would need
an American Lawyer but I will review
that Audrey after the stream and get
back to you so thank you very very much
Pete questions about drums how long have
I been playing do I have an acoustic set
of drums I've been playing for about 13
years
I have an acoustic set of drums but it
is not here in my apartment because I
don't think that that would be allowed
and I think that that would create major
problems with my neighbours and I don't
really want to do that so I am trying to
be a good neighbor and I have just my
just my snare drum silenced by three
practice paths Matthew Goode tell or get
tell I don't know how it's pronounced
has sent a one dollar super chat thank
you very much
interesting chat message from Miguel
Rodriguez thank you for the David
Sullivan black caller book
recommendation I think it's a novel
every American should read it yeah so
it's actually it's Daniel Sullivan
Daniel Sullivan wrote a really cool
novel called black collar we connected
because he's not only a fan of the show
but he he and I both when we were
younger worked at the now-defunct
Circuit City retail chain selling
electronics and we traded war stories
for lack of a better term via email and
I really liked his book it's a really
cool book very exciting read and I
highly recommend it to you and yeah
Daniel Sullivan black collar very very
cool book Matthew cattell has sent
another super chat for $5 would you
refute Ben Shapiro's talking points in a
deep dive I am I'm an okay I would be up
for exploring that Matthew but I don't
know which talking points you're talking
about I think you know he talks about so
many political issues it would be
important I think to drill down a
a bit and see exactly which topic you
want you you want us to look into but
I've had been on the show we exchange
emails every once in a while and I would
have no problem whatsoever refuting
talking points if I believe that he is
wrong okay I am sad to say it I don't
think we're gonna hit 1880 patrons I've
got to run in three or four minutes and
we are just three short we started the
evening at 1863 we have reached 1877 we
need only three more three more patreon
contributions of as little as one dollar
a month and I'm worried we're gonna fall
short because we're only three away it
slowed down over the last ten minutes or
so and I literally am about to hit a
hard stop because I don't want to be up
all night preparing tomorrow's programs
so if there are any last at this point
there are three people out there who by
virtue of contributing as little as a
dollar a month could make it so that
dozens of people are able to take
advantage of a 59 percent discount off
of david pakman show membership s-- if
there is anyone at left out there who
wants to make these last minute dollar
contributions it doesn't have to be more
than adult we can trigger that fifty
nine percent coupon code but I am I'm
staying as long as I can because I want
to see this succeed but I am going to
have to I'm hitting my hard stop soon I
did see a couple people asking about
future live streams because we're going
to be on vacation starting after this
week I do tentatively plan to do at
least one extra live stream I've been
doing two a week lately last week I
squeezed an extra one in on Friday late
Friday and I tentatively plan to do in
the next three days I hope to do at
least two live streams
okay so that
hopefully will be an extra thing for
everybody I will do a couple additional
live streams this week
Jacob Ball has pledged has made a $3 and
thirty three cent super chat saying so
close
it's either sad face or or know it's a
crime face crying face question about
the Patriots in the chat for this season
how do I see the New England Patriots I
feel very very positive about the New
England Patriots for this upcoming
season i I do believe that increasingly
football is heading to a some kind of
cliff because of the concussion crisis
chronic traumatic encephalopathy brain
injury but I I do still enjoy watching
the Patriots play we are now only two
patreon pledges away from hitting our
target of eighteen eighty because of the
very generous $2 a month contribution of
says II Canales we are at 1878 what a
bummer it would be if we fall after
coming so far with 15 new pledges if we
end up just to patreon pledges short we
now have 1879 patreon pledges we've
received an additional dollar pledge and
we are closing in because of the pledge
of Justin Turner and Bryan shaloo with a
$2.00 a month pledge may have put us
over the edge I wonder if Bryan shaloo
has made it happen with 1880 pledges
let's see are we at 1880 boy is my
patreon pledge taking a long time a
patreon page taking a long time to
refresh have we reached 1880 we have not
we are at 1879 know someone is saying we
did hit it I'm not seeing that I don't
know why I'm not seeing that mine still
says 1879 started at 1863 that I know
and we are now at 1,800
and 79 people are saying we've hit but
I'm not seeing that I see it I see 1880
why is that not working on my side hmmm
patreon am I on some kind of delay am I
on a slower internet or an Internet
using maybe narrower tubes that is not
allowing me to see 1880 there it is
we've hit okay let's put together that
coupon code we have hit 1880 this is a
very very good thing it would have been
really sad if we saw that go to waste I
will create a new coupon code what's in
the news that would be a funny coupon
code maybe this one is of course going
to be 59 percent off of the membership
of your choice what would be a funny
coupon code that would be related to the
news that's going on that Stephen Miller
but I don't really want to do a Stephen
Miller related coupon code what about
something relative to God Trump's golf
vacation what about Golf time 17 Golf
times 17 is going to be our coupon code
for today and I will put that into the
video description coupon code golf times
17 that will allow you to get the David
Pakman show membership of your choice
for fifty nine percent off and that is a
really really great thing enjoy that you
can keep that price for membership as
long as you want the coupon goes in the
coupon code field on page two page two
of the membership sign up page one last
Super chat I'm glad we made it it would
have been really sad if we didn't jacob
ball has sent an $18 and 80 cent super
chat saying go Brian
that's right go Brian Dylan call it has
sent a $2.00 super chat loved your work
practicing that drum behind you I do
practice I've got my yeah people
mentioned this earlier I've got my snare
drum with three deadening practice pads
on it because I live in an apartment and
don't want to annoy my neighbors so yes
I do practice using that thanks to
everybody who supported us today super
chat membership patreon to more streams
at least
is my intention this week since-- will
be on vacation next week so I will talk
to you soon on super chat on the
livestream and of course on the regular
broadcast program